when i'm juggling
i feel like i have a superpower
to me it's just an amazing feeling to
keep lots of things in the air and to
keep these big patterns going
sam malcolm is a combat juggler
the object of the sport is to keep all
three pins in the air while preventing
your opponent from doing likewise
light bumping and armed arm altercations
are permitted
the last juggler standing
wins
i got into combat juggling at about 3am
at a juggling convention
playing around with some friends
just trying to see who could be the last
one standing
we've all been to circuses we've all
seen variety acts
but this is something that makes it more
of a sport
if you're playing football you have to
put in the work to get good at football
juggling is no different you have to put
in hours and hours and hours of practice
you're not only accounting for the three
objects that you're juggling you have to
anticipate that there could be something
flying at your head
from 50 feet in the air because it's so
wild and crazy there's so many other
people playing
i warm up for combat juggling i jump
rope for about 10 minutes i work on
balancing things on my head and on my
face
there's a lot of wild throws there's a
lot of wild saves there's a lot of
jumping around and falling and running
on the ground and i try to go through
all of those things to get ready
you see
incredible plays by people like steph
curry or lebron james i can look at
those people and tell you like they'd be
great jugglers because they have that
awareness over their body
it's something new and exciting and
fresh something fun and something
different
so i'm optimistic that it'll grow and
become something really great
you